so george i saw your appearance on the
view it was a great honor to see you on
the view i think you're one of the best
guests
you were so honest
they asked you about the japan parade
and you started talking about uh being a
gay man and you knew you were young you
were a gay man and you talked about your
friend's uh butt crack that you could
see and you went over to play marbles
and i thought this is the greatest
television oh here is a gay man talking
about when he discovered he was gay and
they shut you up they shut you right
down were you offended by this on the
view
no because i was a guest and
they're the boss and we had
actually we didn't have a conversation i
thought that's that's what it was going
to be a conversation to give and take
but they all shut up and they just
grinned at me and
i feel a void there was a boy
so i kept on talking and talking and and
i was running out of things to talk
about so i introduced
my childhood uh when i was
uh discovering that i was different in
ways other than just i japanese face i
loved it uh but here let's revisit it
this is uh george decay on the view
sharing intimate thoughts when i
turn 9 and
10 and 11
i
sense that i was different from the
others
bobby corell
had the sweetest smile
or
richard montana
was very athletic
and his mother didn't uh buy new clothes
for him
i grew up in east l.a
all mexican-american barrio and when
richard montana hunkered down to play
marbles his tight t-shirt
went up and his tight pant jeans
crept down and i saw a little bit of the
small of his back okay it was very
exciting so i grew up knowing i was
different right right
you know i loved that story but you
could see
that joy got very uptight
right
right right brad you were upset he was
there to support the japan parade he was
invited by the government of japan the
consul general ambassador of new york
and so he starts talking about butt
cracks
but cleavage have you two consider going
into couples therapies
that's what we're doing right now
you're not kidding this is it what about
it i have to disagree with uh brad i i
believe that that appearance was
truthful
it was um it was certainly interesting i
liked hearing about richard montana's
ass crowd and i thought it was fabulous
i did he was cute
it was a lousy plug for the japan parade
well that's true